The Joe Rogan Experience speaking of
which did you see the new video of the
[__] Q Anon Shaman being led through
the Capitol building by police no what
what happened there you know this is the
story of the violent Insurrection oh
yeah that's the narrative it was I mean
by the way let's just be real clear
you shouldn't break into the [__]
Capitol Building you shouldn't be trying
to overthrow the government you
shouldn't be trying to like get out
there and say that the election was
false when you don't exactly know you're
just buying into it and then you all
invade the capital wasn't good wasn't a
good look for America it wasn't good for
any of the people there nothing nothing
was good about January 6th let's be real
clear but when you watch the video of
that guy being led around uh through the
Capitol building by police they're
basically giving him like a tour they're
talking to him and hanging out with him
at one point in time it's him and
there's like six police officers around
him and they're not arresting him
they're not throwing him to the ground
there's no violence at all
like I don't I don't think what that guy
did was good I think when any of those
people did was good it wasn't smart
[__] barge into the capital and take
pictures of your feet on Nancy Pelosi's
desk it's [__] stupid it's it's it's
a crime
but they were leading him around like
they were hey the cops were talking to
him and hanging out with him wasn't they
weren't like arresting him immediately
it wasn't like he was this violent guy
who broke and started smashing things
and [__] together they stayed between
the Velvet ropes these watched the video
yeah so have you seen the video no I
have not seen the video Let's see if you
can find it because Tucker Carlson
highlighted it on his television show
and now everybody's up in arms because
it's coming from Tucker but it should be
coming from the New York Times too it
should be coming from everybody it says
this is video footage of this guy and
it's a thing that's different than what
we're being told it is we're being told
that they barged in [__] brah and
they overtook the capital locked them up
put him in jail
seems edited though I'll be honest with
yes
both both it's definitely
various ways it's definitely edited but
when you see the video itself you do see
these cops walking around with this guy
and they're they're essentially it's
like they're giving them a tour it
doesn't seem like what we're what we
thought it was but the other thing is I
thought it was like they broke in and
then they [__] scared the cops away
and there were so many of them that they
overtook the capital I'm gonna get a lot
of heat for this and I don't care where
was President Trump for these people
these are his strongest supporters he
did not stick his neck out for them in
the slightest he let them rot in jail
is that the one I don't that's it I
can't tell because I'm not listening to
it so so here it is
but it turns out there's quite a bit of
video you haven't seen and that video
tells a very different story about what
happened on January 6th oh they're
fixing it a thousand hours or
surveillance footage from in and around
the capitol have been withheld from the
public and once you see the video you'll
understand why taken as a whole the
video record does not support the claim
that January 6 was an Insurrection in
fact it demolishes that claim
and that's exactly why the Democratic
party and its allies in the media
prevented you from seeing it by
controlling the images you were allowed
to view from January 6th they controlled
how the public understood that day
they could lie about what happened and
you would never know the difference
those lies had a purpose they created a
pretext for a federal Crackdown on
opponents of the uni party in Washington
our office wants to ensure that there
was shock and all that we could charge
as many people as possible the first
thing you notice from viewing the full
video record of January 6th is just how
many people entered the Capitol building
that day holy [__] hundreds and hundreds
of people possibly thousands over the
course of about two hours the crowd was
enormous a small percentage of them were
Hooligans they committed vandalism
you've seen their pictures again and
again
but the overwhelming majority weren't
they were peaceful they were orderly and
meek these were not insurrectionists
they were sightseers footage from inside
the capitol overturns the story you've
heard about January 6th protesters queue
up in neat little lines they give each
other tours outside the speaker's office
they take cheerful selfies and they
smile they're not destroying the capital
they obviously Revere the capital
they're there because they believe the
election was stolen from them they
believe in the system
here's the man you've heard referred to
as the Q Anon Shaman outside the Senate
chamber these are not rioters these are
people who wandered over from a
political rally we will not let them
silence your voices after the rally they
walk down Pennsylvania Avenue where
organizers had secured a federal permit
to hold a legal rally on the grounds of
the capital I know that everyone here
will soon be marching over to the
Capitol Building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard once at the Capitol
Building Things began to get chaotic
Capitol police officers fired tear gas
into the crowd a few at the front of the
herd broke Windows someone opened the
doors and many hundreds of others just
walked in
of course they did make it the story and
at the center of it was that Alex's
famous person arrested that day was a
Navy veteran from Arizona called Jacob
chansley often referred to as the Q Anon
Shaman the so-called Q Anon Shaman Q
Anon Shaman someone named Q Shaman Jacob
chansley became the face of January 6th
a dangerous conspiracy theorist dressed
in outlandish costume who led the
violent Insurrection to overthrow
American democracy for these crimes
chansley was sentenced to nearly four
years in prison far more time than many
violent criminals now receive what did
Jacob chansley do to receive this
punishment
to this day there is dispute over how
chansley got into the Capitol building
but according to our review of the
internal surveillance video it is very
clear what happened once he got inside
virtually every moment of his time
inside the capitol was caught on tape
the tape show that Capitol Police never
stopped Jacob chansley they helped him
they acted as his tour guides wow here's
video of chance they're opening the door
for him Capitol police officers take him
to multiple entrances and even try to
open lock doors for him we counted at
least nine officers who were within
touching distance of unarmed Jacob
chansley not one of them even tried to
slow him down
chancelly understood that Capitol Police
were his allies video shows him giving
thanks for them in a prayer on the floor
of the Senate watch
contrast the reality of what Jacob
chansley did in the Capitol building on
January 6. indisputable facts recorded
on video some of which has never before
been seen with the depiction of Jacob
chansley that you've seen in the media
for more than two years he's a terrorist
they said he should be killed shoot him
shoot him like if it you burst into the
United States and if he was dressed like
Bin Laden would have shot him shoot him
no shoot him
it makes you wonder who are the violent
extremists here not Jacob chansley and
the video proves that but she would
never have known from the media coverage
the people sitting in the chairs wild
right you're not supposed to go into the
Capitol Building Grant I thought it's I
thought you at certain times not like
that yeah I don't like that not like
that but
when you see the people taking them
around essentially on a tour that's not
what I thought it was it's I I just hope
all the conservatives watching this
realize how little appetite there is in
the Republican party for defending
people like this and thinking that Mitch
McConnell Donald Trump care about this
is is a delusion it's not even defending
them it's just forget about it let's
look at what what actually happened we
didn't know that happened right we had a
version of it was this chaos and the
cops ran away and a copper cops were
murdered
yeah I would have never imagined that
this I'm shocked to see that it's so
wild
and it's and that and like to your point
that it's not a bigger story that it's
[__] Tucker who's covering this it's
just broken and I think people are
starting to pay attention to it now I
think it's by Design I think it's work
it's by Design it's not an accident no I
mean it just broke I mean like oh yeah
yeah okay
um I think it's really recent and so I
think people are just starting to
recognize that uh it's not what you
thought it was
it's not good to get in it's not good
but they did clearly you want a
peacefully protest you do it outside you
don't ever go into the [__] Capitol
building if someone smashes his door
don't enter behind it I I don't see how
not having him under house arrest
wouldn't be infinitely preferable to
putting him in jail which is cheaper
stay in your house they're putting him
in jail for four years like what who's
that he's not violent there's no concern
that he's gonna kill someone or assault
yeah
he pled guilty of course he did of
course he played that if he doesn't play
guilty they give him 25 yes yeah and he
was guilty he was there 100 guilty he
definitely should be so there should be
some kind of punishment for doing that
to make sure that people don't do that
well wouldn't it be better if he did
actually community service to help the
community clean up go [__] clean up
clean up yeah go clamp that wall yeah
like do that for like four years every
weekend you have to go to the mall clean
up broken glass fine the problem is like
with those kind of protest things man
the the mob has a mind of his own and if
you are in that mob and you just follow
along with it and all of a sudden they
have your [__] face it doesn't even
seem like the mob because it wasn't like
they were knocking [__] pulling off of
walls but that's also selective right
sure of course this is the thing they're
showing us only the good stuff if we
wanted to watch all of it I think
there's some insane amount of hours of
footage and this has only been recently
released so who knows what else we can
see I think it's just very sad that we
had these big hearings for a long time
and they must have had this footage and
they sat on it yeah it's crazy
I feel bad for those people because they
were duped yeah they really thought that
like Trump had their back and this is
okay and you know we're America like the
whole little narrative I also feel bad
for people like that guy saying shoot
him shoot him why because now if he sees
his video he's going to realize like oh
no he won't I was misinformed no way you
don't double down he will absolutely
double down really 100
Capitol Police Chief blast Tucker
Carlson over misleading January 6
footage video aired by Carlson showed Q
Anon Shaman Jacob Chancey accompanied by
police but not violence on the day Riot
or stormed the capital and so what is he
saying about it being misleading uh Fox
bucks people didn't respond to comment
when asked claimed by Carlson the
Capitol Police served as tour guides for
Joe Johnson the horn wearing Q Anon
Shaman was outrageous and false manager
wrote he said that the Capitol Police
were badly outnumbered on January 6th
and that those officers did their best
to use de-escalation tactics try to talk
rioters into getting each other to leave
the bill building okay that makes sense
that makes sense but that's still not
the opening doors for him that's still
not the same narrative because that's is
that de-escalation tactics you can see
it take a look at it but you guys got to
leave well I was looking at it I thought
maybe that they were taking him out not
in handcuffs obviously which maybe they
should have if they thought he did bad
but leading him out of the building
that's why the one cops didn't react
like he's taking him out maybe they're
looking for an exit but it seemed like
they were looking for an entrance
because he was saying that he gave
thanks to the the police officers
it seemed very clear also that there was
no possibility that he was going to be
violent toward them like they were not
clearly in fear of their lives or that
he was going to swing on them or
anything like that no no no not at all I
mean they were talking to him yeah he he
thanked them he gave a prayer and
thanked them
it's it's a very unfortunate thing four
years is no it's four years it's a long
[__] time it's a long time to be
locked up Carlson says they checked with
the Capitol Police
before in the video he said we're happy
to say their reservations were minor and
for the most part they were reasonable
Capital police spokesman Tim Barber said
that we repeatedly request that any
Clips be shown to us first for a
security review so far we have only been
given the ability to preview a single
clip out of the multiple clips that
aired so they didn't show them all of it
so they wanted and his attorney didn't
have that footage wow
holy crap chansey's attorney uh through
sentencing in November 2021 said he had
been provided many hours of video by
prosecutors but not the footage which
Carlson aired on Monday night he said
that he had not seen video of chansley
walking through Capitol hallways with
multiple Capitol police officers what's
deeply troubling Watkins said Tuesday is
the fact that I have to watch Tucker
Carlson to find video footage what the
government has but chose not to disclose
despite the absolute duty to do so
despite being requested in writing to do
so multiple times you can't I'm not an
attorney but I know enough that if
you're a prosecutor you're holding
evidence that could clear the defendant
that's not legal because Discovery means
you have to turn over all the evidence
not just things that will incriminate
him it's ugly
wow
can you imagine if this gets overturned
or he gets to wow yeah it says Carlson's
program conveniently cherry-picked from
the calmer moments of our over 41 000
hours of video manager wrote yeah the
commentary fails to provide context
about the chaos and violence that
happened before or during these less
tense moments well that's fair sure
Carlson previously produced a three-part
Series in 2021 called Patriot Purge on
the streaming service Fox Nation which
suggested the riot was orchestrated by
antifa groups the FBI and other
government agencies and was a false flag
operation to discredit Trump supporters
but
here's the thing the FBI was asked if
they used Asian provocateurs on January
6 and they refused to answer I'm sure
you've seen that footage yes yeah and
they know about that guy Ray Epps that
was on the capitol grounds saying we got
to go in there and and people are
calling him a fed and nothing's happened
to that guy nothing's happened to that
guy but the guy was clearly inciting
these people to do something illegal and
they know who he is they have it on tape